Hey guys, how's it going? So there's been a lot [of] apple news in the past couple of days
[and] [I] have missed all of it. So I've been traveling and I've been missing out on some serious Apple news well today
I caught up and the one headline they caught my eye
Actually headlines cuz its pretty much what everyone's talking about. would a would a free pair of AirPods [ease] the pain of the iPhone 8's thousand dollar price tag
The iPhone 8 may actually come with Apples best accessory. Will iphone 8 come bundled with free air Pods
free headphones
I think this is going to be an incredible decision if apple does decide to do this because
The headphones that come with your phone now
Yeah, they're great, but the air pods are fantastic, and I know I have made fun of them
[I've] made all [of] the jokes possible, but when it comes down to it
Yeah, they don't stay in my ears perfectly, but man
They are the best pair of headphones that I have ever really used
Just on the ease of use, the supportability they sink to everything and they just freakin work. I have yet. I
oh wait i was gonna say i have yet to lose the AirPods. I have actually lost a set, i  i forgot about that
There's no good story about how I lost it. I didn't just lose the air pods that go into my ear
I lost the entire case
[Justine cries]
i have lost both air pods in the package entirely, but I have not lost a single AirPod
So I feel like that's a step in the right direction, right?
(giggles)
the rumors are the iphone 8 is going to be a thousand dollars. There's also rumors that they're not going to be available
There's only gonna be a minimum amount of them. Let's take [a] peek at that. New Evidence
iPhone 8 faces worst Case
Shortage scenario iphone 8 facing huge barriers that will cost shortages the firm is revising
(mumbles)
what are the components
What are they so they're dropping the original shipments from [100] [to] [110] million units down to 80 to 90?
What does that mean does that mean?
does that mean i'm not gonna get a phone? Does that mean you're not gonna get a phone? What does it mean?
[mumbles]
Apple is still expected to announce two of the devices [the] iPhone 7s
The iphone 7s [plus] which may still launch in september guys these are all rumors. I don't even know
What got me really hyped was the fact that the air pods may come with the iphone 8 a lot of people were saying that
This is not [possible] like this can't actually happen because there's such a shortage of air pods currently
Maybe the reason there's a shortage is because they plan on giving you a nice pair [of] AirPods with your iphone 8
could it be?
Could it be people are still struggling to get air pods when I lost mine in Hawaii
I ended up having to ebay mine
So that I could have them the next day because I'm crazy and I was not able to live without them
This is my thought if they decide to give you the air pods in the iphone 8 will they make the iphone 8
USB-C to compensate for your troubles. Yes
Please compensate me for my trouble of having a USB-C iphone 8 because truthfully it's not a trouble to me at all
Only people who's troubling will be are those upgrading who do not have any other USB-C products, but man
I am so, I'm going all in with
USB-C, baby it is what I want
It's what I live for, I wake up in the morning and I have some [USB-C] with the side of eggs and toast
That doesn't even make any sense.
What's this?
iphone [8] Edge to Edge horizontally glass back iphone 7s AirPods
What kind of title is this you've got a lot of information?
that title! so what I'm wondering from you guys is what do you think they're going to do is you think that the iPhone 8?
is going to now be
USB-C and to compensate for that change are they gonna give us some air pods for free?
You're still buying, so you're buying them
just don't ever let anyone tell [you] that you're getting those for free
But I do see where people are coming from
With the speculation because if they are giving those to us most of the people to buy that phone are
probably also going to want to buy some sort of headphones whether it's the air pods or
Some other wireless choice. I'm not sure
there's a lot of them out there
[I'm] also super pumped about all of the rumors of a smart home device a Siri in my house
We've already got the google home. We've got Amazon's Alexa and we also have let me show you this
Amazon show
Amazon officially unveiles touch screen echo show. Looks like something you'd see at the dentist or like a dentist kiosk
[I] don't know why
dentist kiosk is what I thought of maybe [because] I cracked one of my teeth
And I'm still trying to recover from that.
What's this guy doing?
[talk] [ Alexa accept the call]
[Hey, mom] [Hi honey. How are things?]
[Ah. You forgot to mention how hard this whole parenting thing would be] [and you are forgetting what your new print says]
[aha thats. Heyy]
This is Jody first time mom
[Here's the cutie] [Hi] and
okay, but Echo [would you like?]
Okay, I'm just scrolling this video, but let me tell you what if this is what Amazon is releasing
What do you think apple could be doing that is better than this, don't get me wrong [I] freaking love Amazon
But when apple does something and they do it, right?
They do it right [so] with all of the technology that's out there with a google home and Alexa and now an echo show
What could apple possibly potentially be launching? What have they already made? What do they have that is ready for [our]?
for our home. I'm getting so excited!
so the echo show is [229] which is kind of a, see it's a fairly steep price because you could buy a freakin
Laptop for that like how much is the Microsoft surface yeah surface laptop is
999 Dollars
granted you're not going to have the sort of
Interactivity and a placement that you're going to have with the Amazon echo show but look at this you [get] a whole freaking computer I
i just feel like a 229. I don't know you got to make some [decisions]
What [oh God] I don't know I'm freaking out with all these like potential things that are coming out
Anyway, I just wanted to give you guys a quick little roundup
my thoughts are everywhere because just sitting here with you guys and
Surfing the web and looking up all of these things that could [potentially] be out the rumors are they true? What's gonna
What are we gonna have? I don't know [since] I have been traveling I've been so appreciative for you guys
tweeting the updates and all kinds of cool [things]
I know a lot [of] you guys, but also like to see me try the New oreo
Firecracker fireworks cookies, I'm on the lookout for that. But right now. We're going to jump cut from here
We are heading to Chicago which I've actually just got back
[I'm] currently in New York right now
So I went from New York to Chicago [back] to New York
But what I didn't tell [you] at the beginning of my Chicago vlog is why I was there
I went to Chicago to be on the Steve Harvey show
And I had the best time ever
[it] was so much fun [that] episode will be airing later this month or maybe next month
I'm not a 100% sure but when I find out I will let you guys know on Twitter or Instagram or wherever else. Here we go
Let's go to Chicago
Hey, Chicago! We're here!
We're going up the willis tower
This used to be known as the Sears tower and I kept calling the Sears tower and everyone kept correcting me, so
Willis, we're here
We're here! ohhh man
(Justine's shook)
We are about to get a picture, the shot in the sky box. [oh], you're making me so nervous
Wow. This is
This is pretty terrifying
[Can you look up here?] Okay
[one. two]
(camera clicks)
Just got the coolest shot ever. Check this out
Tell me why you didn't do? wouldn't do it? [refused]
I'm a big chicken. I can't.
I really can't. it's okay. It's okay. You made it up here though, so im super proud. Yeah. Thank you.
(And he looked over that) He did. [And i threw up all over the place]
When in Chicago you go to Portillo's
We just ordered and now waiting for orders.When you guys hear 223
That's us. We got everything. I mean if you're going to do Portillo's, you gotta do Portillo's
(Alright, there you go) Thank you
These bags are really heavy
oh my god
I know I did something really bad. I got a salad at Portillo's, please don't yell at me, please don't yell at me!
[It looks good though] It looks really good.
oh my Gosh
[I don't know] [laughs]
That, right there. I'm concerned with all of our safety
[OH MY GOD]
So that's the [big beef] and let me tell you what, it is appropriately named
(alarm goes off)
Good morning. [oh] my goodness
If I even tried to explain to you, I guess it's not that difficult to explain yesterday
I cracked a tooth here in Chicago. I'm in Chicago. What do I do?
I don't have a dentist here
So I tweeted asking for dentists and the reason that I'm in Chicago is im going on the Steve harvey show, today.
Right now It's 7:28 a.m.
I have to be in the car by 7:30 to one of Steve harvey's recommended dentist
By [8:00] o'clock then to the studio by 10:00 a.m.. For rehearsal, and then we shoot the show, so that's what's happening today
[I'm] also sleeping in all of my clothes, and I also have my apple watch on and I'm also ready to go
oh yeah i staged the sleeping shot, no kidding.
Good morning, Chicago
Lets just hope nothing serious is wrong cuz i've only got like an hour and a half to do whatever it is they need to do
So whatever happens today. Hopefully it'll last me until
Whenever I get back. We're done at the dentist everything is awesome. I have a temporary fix.
Now we're about the head in to do rehersals for Steve Harvey and I've got a lot of stuff
And Damiano is filming also have my backpack
[somehow] we got a vlog, walk
But this is the life that we life
shoot
We're behind the scenes now. We're here just waiting
Look I spotted
[Hey. Hey.Hey] How are you? [I am fantastic.] Yeah, are you excited for this episode of whatever we're doing that we can't talk about?
[Yeah, you know. I'm very very excited. I sound excited too]
Hi, hello. (Hi) Are you excited? (Yeah I am)
Well, they already know where I'm going. Yeah I already gave them, you wanna say his name? (Steve Harvey?) Yeah (laughs) (How crazy is that?)
I know, i know wow
(I brought my mom, It's so crazy, i brought my mom here) Hi. How are you? [I'm great. I'm so excited also]
[Okay that's enough out of you all right] you be nice to her [I am being nice to her, that's how i be nice to her, I'm acknowledging her assistence]
(He does this all the time, people on instagram tell like - [okay like]
- just treat me nicer) [You wanna talk about this? just start a channel, how about that?] (I'm definitely-)
I think she should, I'll come on as a guest and I've got some words to say as well
I'm gonna work on them. What do we got back here
Bart's getting in a trouble
All right, that's it. We're done filming. This was such a long day, but everything was shot. super fun
I'll let you guys know when the episode actually airs and
I'll be posting some behind the scenes stuff from the actual show that I couldn't show in this vlog sometime later
so stay tuned for that
I gotta go I gotta get on the plane and I have to head back to New [York]
And I don't think my flight lands until like 1:00 a.m.
And then [have] to be up super early tomorrow morning for more press stuff. So come with me friends. Let's go
Let's go. [Peace out] I can't believe we have to run the airport right now. It's like a 9.50 flight
Bye, [bye]. Thanks Steve Harvey, so fun. Lets roll
[The pizza] the pizza
Oh, I gotta bring my sandwich
Bye guys bye. Say bye to the vlog
(Bye!) Have so much fun. [bye. bye. bye) See ya.
Did you get the snaps? [I got them, i got the, oh these are the black ones? i bought coral, i have the coral ones now too] (I have coral ones too)
(we could go out together dressed like yellow on the coral boys) i love it [Coral boys] I'm a girl [coral boys for 2022]
[Coral boys featuring] (You don't have coral?) Yes i do (oh you have corals too?) I have all the colors. (Fine then, you have to come up with the black) [You bet you have all the colors] I have a problem.
This is it. This is the final countdown.
You guys have to see what Domiano is doing right now hold on let me show them, let me show them.
Let me show. He was holding the camera on top of the pizza (i was making do
Flight boards
in 5 minutes, we're almost there
(yayy)
We made it. It's like 1:00 a.m.. But the good news Domiano's pizza made it all the way here
[jesus, made it] it's here [survived] made it
It's 12:31 and now we've gotta drive back to the city. but we're here, am i okay? NO.
I'm very very TIRED
there it is, there it is. That's my book.
Oh gosh, we got another day of fun press and ahh..
First thing done. Most importantly [you've] got your pizza home yesterday. Yes
[YAASSS, and I had some for breakfast]
No judgements [Laughs]
I spilled almost its entire latte on my lap and thankfully
It's just like sunk into my skin and into my body and into my pants
And you can't even tell thankfully I didn't get any on the car. It was just all [over] myself
Hey, guess what I did
Spilt this on my lap. [No] you can't tell look I mean [what about [the] burns?]
It [wasn't] hot thankfully all right. We're going into [South] Code live hosted by Frankie Grande and
That's what we're doing right now
Alright guys. We're here! South Code Live. let's go
We are in green room now. Just waiting to [go] on we're doing an unboxing today, and I'm super excited about it
It's going to be out in I think like a week or so. We'll see TBD. I'll tweet about it. So you'll see it on my twitter.
[look] at all these [boxes] of items
Look at this. Purses!
We just [finished] up the segment. It was super fun. I will put a link in description
Where you guys can check out Frankie's show and where's Frankie, where he at? We just did something
I don't want to [say] what we did yet, because it's not out yet. [so] it will be out very very soon
HI [Hi] How are you? [So excited!]
So you got from playlists. [I took it back and playlist. I launched my merch line you can check it all out]
on my website shopper by frankie.com.] should i put it in [the] description? [yes]
the link's below [Please do] So what else's new? you got so much stuffs going on
[So much stuff is going. When is this posting?] if I'll post it tomorrow? [if you post this tomorrow]
[then I'm doing a show in London on the 27th at which you can pre-order tickets to] [you should also put the link down there if you want]
Guys I'm just gonna put all of Frankie's links. So you know there's no description at this point. FRANKIE! FRANKIE! FRANKIE!
So what else is new? Oh my gosh. I haven't seen you since I think like the Streamys, maybe or something, a long time ago?
[I mean, well you're here on South Code live which is amazing.] True. this show was so much fun. I love it.
[isn't it a fun show? it's super cute and then something else is coming up] Cool. Well you guys stay tuned for that.
Well thanks for being in my vlog. bye love you
[Let's get the light right, over here, okay much better. Thank you!]
That brings this vlog to a close if you guys enjoyed it, and I will see you in tomorrow's video
Whatever that happens to be unless I don't post the video tomorrow, and you could just maybe rewatch another one. I'll see you later. Bye